This lecture is about opinion mining
and sentiment analysis covering its
motivation.
In this lecture we are going to start
talking about mining a different kind
of knowledge, namely knowledge about
the observer or humans that have
generated text data.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the opinion mining and sentiment
analysis.
As we discussed earlier, text data can
be regarded as the data generated from
humans as subjective sensors.
In contrast, we have other devices such
as video recorder that can report
what's happening in the real world
objectively to generate the video data,
for example.
Now the main difference between text data
and other data like video data is that
it has rich and rich opinions and the
content tends to be subjective because
it's generated from humans.
Now this is actually unique advantage
of text data,
as compared with other data
because it offers us a great
opportunity to understand the
observers.
We can mine the text data to understand
the opinions, understand the people's
preferences, how people think about
something.
So this lecture and
the following lectures will be mainly
about how we can mine and analyze
opinions buried in a lot of text data.
So let's start with the concept of
opinion that it's not that easy to
formally define opinion, but mostly we
would define opinion as a subjective
statement describing what a person
believes or thinks about something.
Now I highlighted a quite a few words
here, and that's because it was
thinking a little more about these
words and that would help us better
understand what's in the opinion and this
further helps us to define opinion more
formally, which is always needed to
computationally solve the problem of
opinion mining.
So let's first look at the keyword
subjective here.
Now this is in contrast with objective
statement or factual statement.
Those statements can be proved right or
wrong.
And this is a key differentiating
factor from opinion, which tends to be
not easy to prove wrong or right
because it reflects what a person
thinks about something.
So in contrast, objective statement can
usually be proved wrong or correct.
For example, you might say this
computer has a
screen and a battery.
Now that's something you can check.
It's either having a battery or not.
But in contrast, if you think about the
sentence such as this laptop has the
best battery.
Or this laptop has a nice screen, now
these statements are more subjective
and it's very hard to prove whether
it's wrong or correct.
So opinion is subjective statement.
And next, let's look at the keyword
person here and that indicates this
opinion Holder 'cause when we talk
about opinion, it's about the opinion
held by someone and then we notice that
there is something here.
So that's the target of the opinion.
The opinions is expressed on this
something.
And now, of course, believes or thinks
implies that the opinion would depend on
the culture or background and context
in general, because of person might
think differently in the different
context.
People from different background may
also think in different ways.
So this analysis shows that there are
multiple elements that we need to
include in order to characterize
an opinion.
So what's the basic opinion
representation like, well,  it should include
at least three measurements, right?
First it has to specify what's the
opinion Holder.
So whose opinion is this, second must also
specify the target.
What's this opinion about?
And 3rd, of course we want opinion
content and So what exactly is the
opinion?
If you can identify this, we get a
basic understanding of an opinion and can
already be useful.
Sometimes if you want to understand
further, we want to enrich the opinion
representation.
And that means we also want to
understand, for example, the context of
the opinion and what situation was
opinion expressed.
For example, in what time was it
expressed?
We also would like to deeply understand
opinion sentiment and this is to
understand,
what the opinion tells us about the
opinion holder's feeling, for example,
is this opinion positive or negative?
Or perhaps the opinion holder was
happy or sad.
And so such understanding obviously
goes beyond just extracting the opinion
content and needs some analysis.
So let's take a simple example of a
product review.
In this case, this actually explicit
opinion Holder and explicit target,
so it's
It's obviously what's opinion Holder,
and that's just a reviewer, and it's
also often very clear what's the
opinion target, and that's the
product being reviewed.
For example iPhone 6.
When the review was posted, usually you
can extract such information
easily.
Now the content of course is the review
text that's in general also easy to
obtain.
So you can see product reviews are
fairly easy to analyze in terms of
obtaining a basic opinion
representation.
But of course, if you want to get more
information, we might want to know the
context.
For example, the review was written in
2015.
Or we want to know that the sentiment
of this review is positive, and so this
additional understanding of course adds
value to mining the opinions.
Now you can see in this case the task
is relatively easy, and that's
because.
The opinion Holder and opinion target
that have already been identified.
Now let's take a look at the sentence
in the news.
In this case, we have implicit holder
and implicit target.
And the task is in general harder so we
can identify
opinion holder here and that's
governor of Connecticut.
We can also identify the target.
So one target is Hurricane Sandy.
But there is also another target,
which is a hurricane of
1938.
So what's the opinion?
Well, this negative sentiment here
that's indicated by words like a bad
and worst.
And we can also then
identify the context.
New England in this case.
Now unlike in the product review, all these
elements must be extracted by using
natural language processing techniques.
So the task is much harder and we need
a deeper natural language processing.
And these examples also,
suggest that a lot of work can be
easily done for product reviews, and
that's indeed what has happened.
Analyzing sentiment in news is still
quite difficult.
It's more difficult than the analysis
of opinions in product reviews.
Now there are also some other
interesting variations.
In fact, here we're going to
examine the variations of opinions more
systematically.
First, lets think about the opinion
Holder.
Now the Holder could be an individual
or could be a group of people and
sometimes opinion was from a committee
or from a whole country of people.
Opinion Target can also vary a lot.
It can be about 1 entity, a particular
person, a particular product, a
particular policy, etc.
But it could be about a group of
products.
Could be about the product from a
company in general.
Could also be very specific about one
attribute,
attribute of Entity for example.
It's just about the battery of iPhone.
It could be about someone else opinion
and one person might
comment on another persons opinion
etc.
So you can see there is a lot of
variation here that will cause the
problem to vary a lot.
Now opinion content, of course, can
also vary a lot on the surface.
You can identify one sentence opinion
or one phrase opinion, but you can also
have longer text to express the
opinion like a whole article.
And Furthermore, we can identify the
variation in the sentiment or emotion
dimension.
That's about the feeling of the opinion
Holder.
So we can distinguish positive versus
negative or neutral or happy versus
sad, etc.
Finally, the opinion context can also
vary.
We can have simple context, like
different time or different locations,
but there could be also complex text
such as some background topic being
discussed.
So when opinion expressed in the
particular discourse context, it has to
be interpreted in different ways than
when it's expressed in another context,
so the context can be very rich to
improve the entire discourse
context of opinion. From computational
perspective, we're most interested in
what opinions
can be extracted from text data, so it
turns out that we can also
differentiate distinguish different
kinds of opinions in text data from
computation perspective.
First, the Observer might make a
comment about the opinion target in the
observed world.
So in this case we have the author's
opinion.
For example, I don't like this phone at
all, and that's opinion of this author.
In contrast, the text might also
report opinions about others so the
person could also make observation
about another person's opinion and report
this opinion.
So for example, I believe he loves the
painting and that opinion is really
about, is really expressed by
another person.
Here, so it doesn't mean this author
loves that painting.
So clearly the two kinds of opinions
need to be analyzed in different ways
and sometimes in product reviews you
can see, although mostly the opinions
are from this reviewer.
Sometimes a reviewer might mention
opinions of his friend or her friend,
right?
And another complication is that there
may be indirect opinions or inferred
opinions that can be obtained by making
inferences on what's expressed in the
text that might not necessarily look
like opinion.
For example, one statement might be
this phone ran out of battery in just
one hour.
Now this is in a way, a factual
statement, 'cause you know it's either
true or false, right?
You can even verify that.
But from this statement one can also
infer some negative opinions about the
quality of the battery of this phone or
the feeling of the opinion holder about
the battery.
In the opinion, Holder clearly wish the
battery to last longer.
So these are interesting variations
that we need to pay attention to when
we extract opinions.
Also, for this reason about the
indirect opinions.
It's often also very useful to extract
it or whatever the person had said
about the product, and sometimes
factual sentences like this
are also very useful.
So from practical viewpoint, sometimes
we don't necessarily extract the
subjective sentences.
Instead, would you just get all the
sentences that are about opinions that
are useful for understanding the person
or understanding the product that we are
commenting on.
So the task of opinion mining can be
defined as taking text data as input to
generate a set of opinion
representations.
In each representation we should identify
opinion Holder, target content and
context.
Ideally we can also infer opinion
sentiment from the content and context
to better understand
the opinion.
Now often some elements of the
representation are already known.
I just gave a good example,
in the case of product reviews where
the opinion Holder and opinion target
are often explicitly identified, and
that's not why this turns out to be one of the
simplest opinion mining
tasks.
Now it's interesting to think about
other tasks that might be also simple,
because those are the cases where you
can easily build applications by using
opinion mining techniques.
So now that we have talked about what
is opinion mining and we have defined
the task, let's also just talk a little
bit about the why opinion mining is
very important and why it's very
useful.
So here I identify three major reasons,
3 broad reasons.
The first is it can help decision
support.
I can help us optimize our decisions.
We often look at the other peoples
opinions and look at the reader reviews
in order to make a decision like
buying, buying a product, or using the
service.
We also
Would be interested in others opinions.
When we decide whom to vote, for
example.
And policymakers may also want to know
peoples opinions when designing a new
policy.
So that's one general kind of
applications.
And it's very broad, of course.
The second application is to understand
people, and this is also very
important.
For example, it can help understand
peoples preferences.
So and this could help us better serve
people.
For example, we can optimize the
product search engine, optimize
recommender system if we know what
people are interested in, what people
think about products.
It can also help her with advertising,
of course, and we can have targeted
advertising if we know what kind of
people tend to know to like what kind
of product.
Now the third kind of applications can
be called voluntary survey.
Now this is mostly to support
research that used to be done by doing
surveys, doing manual surveys, questioning
answering.
People need to fill in forms to
answer some questions.
Now this is directly related to humans as
sensors, and we can usually aggregate
opinions from a lot of humans to kind
of assess the general opinion.
Now this is would be very useful for
business intelligence, where product
manufacturers want to know,
where their products have advantages
over others.
What are the winning features of their
product or winning features of
competitive products?
Market research has to do with
understanding consumers opinions and
this is clearly very useful, directed
for that.
Data Driven social science
research can benefit from this because
they can do text mining to understand
the people's opinions.
And if we can aggregate a lot of
opinions from social media from a lot
of public information, then you can
actually do some study of some
questions.
For example, we can study the behavior
of people
on social media or in social
networks, and these can be regarded as
voluntary survey,
but done by those people.
And in general, we can gain a lot of
advantage in any prediction task
because we can leverage the text data
as extra data about any problem and
so we can use text based prediction
techniques to help you make prediction
or improve the accuracy of prediction.